welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and it feels
like a long time since I said that this
episode were going to be breaking down
the newly released Falcon and Winter
Soldier plot details that leaked on
4chan this morning throughout this video
I'll be recapping what the leaks say
happen in the show as well as giving my
reaction to them now there will be heavy
spoilers here and as with all leaks they
should be taken with a pinch of salt but
in the case of Avengers endgame Joker
Game of Thrones and now terminate a dark
fate the leaks often turn out to be true
so you have been warned without the way
I just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Falcon and the Winter
Soldier plot leaks okay so the leaks say
that thunderbull Ross played by William
Hurt and the government don't want Sam
Wilson played by Anthony Mackie to be
the new Captain America due to not
signing the accords they instead enlist
John Walker played by wire Russell to be
the new Captain America who prefers to
go by the name US agent this keeps in
line with the law of the universe and
even at the end of Avengers endgame you
get the feeling that one of the main
reasons that old Steve Rogers has hidden
from the eyes of society
it's because he may still be arrested
did you do not signing the accords the
fact that he passed over the mantle to
Sam as well for them to just overwrite
it makes Sam furious and he gets the
help of Bucky Barnes played by Sebastian
Stan to fight low-level crimes Sharon
Carter played by Emily VanCamp
begs the government to replace Walker
with Sam but Sam and Bucky grow close
with Walker with Sam accepting him as
the new Captain America
I'm guessing they will meet on a street
level and Sam will just resign himself
to the fact that the job is no longer
his however the peace doesn't last long
and Walker gets a chip implanted in his
brain by Zemo played by Daniel Bruhl
resulting in the character going rogue
this is in line with the comics as in
several storylines u.s. agent has been
her villain and watching the government
appointed Captain America going
head-to-head with the real one will be
an awesome plot aesthetic that I think
many fans want to see
Zemo plans to implant ships similar to
the
one he put in walker in the entire
population he gets Rachel Layton played
by body right to help desperate Ross and
the government hire Sam and Bucky to
stop Walker the leak also says that
alfre woodard is Myriam shape and Martin
Freeman as Everett Ross returned in
major roles in addition to this Chris
Evans is back as old Steve Rogers and he
will appear in two episodes possibly to
give moral advice to Sam and Bucky now
we did hear rumors that Chris Evans
wasn't done with the MCU and if this is
how he returns I think he'll be an
amazing way to bring him back I'm
probably the most excited for this news
and if it's true then I think it'll be
great that the character is sort of
acting like a mentor to the pair it may
also flesh out what he went through in
the airs that we didn't get to see when
he went back in time and overall it
makes for an awesome plot device lastly
the leaks say that Yelena Bulova played
by Florence Pugh and Emil Blonsky played
by Tim Roth are expected to cameo
sometime in the series this is going to
tie the series in heavily with Black
Widow and I really can't wait to see how
the movies begin to interact with the
shows now after hearing this I'm
massively interested in the series I
think it sounds really really engaging
and they're ticking all of the boxes for
things that I want to see and a show
that centers around these two characters
it doesn't really mention their
relationship together and how they're
gonna struggle being basically cast to
the side by the government which I think
will definitely be a big factor in the
production it also doesn't mention the
ending of the series and how things go
which most leaks tend to but plot wise
this seems to line up with things that
we already know about the upcoming
Disney Plus shows how will all of the TV
shows that being announced I think that
this is the one I'm most interested in
after one division and there's already a
lot of potential here to create a sort
of spy thriller akin to Captain America
the Winter Soldier which is definitely
one of my favorite MCU movies overall
there's a lot here that I'm really
interested in and I can't wait to see if
the show delivers on its concept because
if these leaks are true then it sounds
brilliant now let me know your thoughts
on the leaks and if these have got you
excited for it comment below to tell me
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my full movie breakdown of
Terminator doc fade would you be linked
at the end we go over the entire film
and give our thoughts on it so it's
definitely worth watching if you want to
know more if you want to come chat to me
after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which would be linked in the description
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with all the latest videos and the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the marble phase 3 part 1
box em blu-ray which contained Civil War
Doctor Strange homecoming or Ragnarok
and more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning it's like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the leaks in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of November and the Celt be
shipped out from then to against the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you